sicherheitspolitischer jahresauftakt
2020 das interesse an dieser
veranstaltung ist diesmal so groß wie
selten zuvor
und das liegt nicht allein an der
teilnahme der neuen
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
nicht nur bei auslandseinsätzen auch im
inland die thema cybersicherheit oder
hybride bedrohungen nur als beispiel
genannt wachsen die herausforderungen
stetig an
ich glaube die veranstaltung ist wichtig
um anlegen dass sicherheitspolitik in
österreich einer breiteren
öffentlichkeit und vor allem eine
entscheidungsträgern nahe zu bringen und
da gibt es eine ereignis dessen
wahrscheinliches eintreten in den
nächsten fünf jahren nicht nur die
experten des bundesheeres mit 100
prozent bewerten
der ausfall des stroms das sogenannte
black out blackout bleibt ein thema es
kam grossflächig sein sektoral wir
müssen diesen gefahren entsprechendes
augenmerk widmen wir wissen schon seit
vielen jahren dass wir dreimal im jahr
an so einem blick ganz knapp
vorbeischrammen in österreich das wissen
wir von unserer austrian power grid und
daher ist es nicht überraschend dass man
jetzt die wahrscheinlichkeit als so hoch
einstufen die vorbereitungen müssen
stimmen
man muss sich geistig darauf einstellen
muss technische vorkehrungen treffen und
man muss wirklich auch in den köpfen
sich wirklich darauf einstellen und das
war glaube ich die botschaft von heute
dass das wirklich so knapp vor der tür
stehen um einen möglicherweise
bevorstehenden massenpanik beim
eintreten eines blackout vorzubeugen
informiert das bundesheer sachlich und
kompetent nicht darüber zu sprechen ist
keine option
langfristig glaube ich nicht dass das
bundesheer sagen kann darüber spricht
man nicht es gibt natürlich
konkreten fall
geheimhaltungsvorschriften und das ist
auch gut und logisch so aber über die
großen gefahren felder und
konfliktfelder die uns alle bedrohen
im langfristigen zusammenhang nicht zu
sprechen und gerade nicht das als
bundesheer einzubringen
das wäre letztlich sogar ein
demokratischer widerspruch